zendaya opens up about sexual harassment  in Hollywood the 21 year old actress  graces the January cover of InStyle  magazine  looking fabulous as ever inside she  praises women for coming forward with  their stories of sexual harassment in  Hollywood being free to do whatever you  want with your own body  zendaya tells the mag I think it's  definitely a sisterhood the bravery of  women who came forward is a huge step  toward making sure it's safer for me and  other young women who are just coming up  I'm growing up and there's a lot of  other things I want to do in my career  zendaya also opened up about her rise to  fame and the responsibilities that come  along with it  admitting being a role model is a huge  part it comes with the territory  her job as for the actresses legacy she  explained I'd rather be known for the  active change I've made than for what my  name stands for  [Music]